the next couple of months are going to
look a little bit different as the
cultural revolution marches on in the
name of diversity inclusion and equity a
seattle school is canceling its annual
halloween parade according to the libs
black people apparently can't carve
jack-o-lanterns in the name of public
health one of the most famous basketball
players in the world is going to be
benched for refusing the fouchy auchi
and as a consequence of those same
public health measures the biden white
house is warning that you might not get
any christmas presents this year but
there is a bright side from school board
meetings to churches to the joe rogan
podcast the people aren't going down
without a fight i'm michael knowles this
is the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from davidson who
says the thing about conspiracies is
sometimes the theories are right well
that's true you saw a lot of that in
2016 2017 2018
we were told it's a conspiracy theory
that the fbi is spying on donald trump
actually even before that we were told
it's a conspiracy that the obama irs is
targeting conservative organizations
it's a conspiracy it's it's a conspiracy
that the virus originated in the wuhan
lab how many
times do these theories need to be
proven correct before we stop calling
them conspiracy theories it's enough to
keep you up at night fortunately i don't
have that problem and i've really got to
thank my friends at helix you know that
you should not be sleeping on someone
else's mattress okay it's scandalous
it's wrong
it's it's it just doesn't make any sense
all right
you got to get your own mattress and
what i'm not i'm not talking about
anything risque i'm just i'm talking
literally about the mattress okay get a
mattress that is made for you go to
helix sleep right now take their
two-minute sleep quiz answer some
questions about the way that you sleep
you can get mattresses that are soft
medium firm mattresses for people who
sleep a little bit hot a helix plus size
mattress helix is the number one rated
overall mattress pick of 2020 from gq
and wired magazine they just do it
better head on over to helixleep.com
knowlescanwlis take that two minute
sleep quiz they will match you to a
customized mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life they've got
a 10-year warranty and you get to try it
out for over a hundred nights risk free
they'll even pick up the bed for you if
you don't like it but you're gonna
absolutely love it head on over to helix
right now they're offering up to 200
bucks off all mattress orders and two
free pillows for our listeners at helix
sleep.com knowles wlas that is helix
sleep.com knowles for up to 200 off and
two free pillows black people can't
carve pumpkins
apparently this is what i have learned
from a school in seattle the school in
seattle has an annual pumpkin parade
that's a sweet thing to do isn't that
nice little kids go around they've got
their pumpkins they carve that's a nice
little fall
halloween tradition
or at least it was at benjamin franklin
elementary school but you see that
school's racial equity team why does it
have a rate i don't know but they have a
racial equity team
this is one of the consequences of
critical race theory and this is one of
the effects of that you see in the world
this critical race theory that begins in
law schools and then permeates our legal
and academic systems to the point that
you have racial equity teams in
elementary schools and to the point that
they cancel pumpkin parades apparently
quote
historically the pumpkin parade
marginalizes students of color who do
not celebrate the holiday
specifically these students have
requested to be isolated on campus while
the event took place this according to a
spokesman from the school talking to our
friend jason ranz who's a radio host in
seattle
the students are like six right so this
we are being told that
and i don't even believe that this is
true but let's just say that it is true
that a six-year-old didn't want to
participate in the school activity we
are being told that is basically the
equivalent of a of a bus boycott
we're told this is basically the
equivalent of the civil rights marches
the march on washington because you see
black people they don't have halloween
that's a white person holiday they don't
have the fall
that the fall is a white person season
what is a black person season i have no
idea
i it seems to me it's pretty
counterproductive to character black
people in this way
as if black people can't can't carve the
pumpkins it actually reminds me of
something that i noticed in college
so i'm in college not that long ago what
was it like 10 years ago less
and i'm in college and
it was martin luther king day
very very liberal liberal college and
they served a special meal in the dining
halls they served barack obama's
favorite fried chicken recipe
and they served a bunch of other
food that's mostly southern food that we
traditionally associate with black
people watermelon that sort of thing
and i i looked at that and i thought
hold on so martin luther king day
on martin luther king day you you have
barack obama's favorite fried chicken
wrist because obama and martin luther
king are both black so that makes total
sense and obama because he's a black guy
man he loves his fried chicken isn't
that right
i doubt that he does i suspect that
barack obama probably prefers mahi-mahi
or something because he grew up in
hawaii and he was raised almost
exclusively by white people and it's
this ridiculous caricature to pretend
that because barack obama's black what
he drinks grape soda or something and he
no because
at these very liberal enlightened
institutions
everyone's got to fit in their little
box and only white people do this and
only black people do this and apparently
this has gone all the way down to this
very woke elementary school where the
black kids can't carve the pumpkins
halloween is not the only holiday being
cancelled though
looking beyond halloween
we are now being told
we were we were excited for a little bit
because dr fauci told us that maybe we
could have christmas this year remember
he canceled it last year then he sort of
canceled it this year and then he got
pushed back and so he said okay maybe
you can have christmas but jen saki over
at the white house says sure you can
celebrate christmas but you ain't gonna
get any presents
based on everything being announced
today yeah can
this administration guarantee
that holiday packages will arrive on
time
we are not the postal service or ups or
fedex we cannot guarantee
what we can do is use every lever at the
federal government disposal to reduce
delays to ensure that we are
addressing bottlenecks in the system
including uh ports and the the need for
them to be open longer hours so that
goods can arrive uh and we can continue
to press uh not only uh workers and
unions but also companies to take as
many steps as they can to reduce these
delays
now i don't want to be too harsh here
and just take pot shots at gensake
because i can
i suppose there is a nice aspect of
reducing the materialism and the
commercialism of christmas and bringing
this the real reason for the season back
into focus uh yes that is that is all
good i'm not sure this is the way to do
it though i don't i don't think that the
way to reduce the commercialism of
christmas
that the best way is necessarily to
destroy the global supply chains and
lock down the world over a cough i don't
know that that's
i i suppose whatever works but what this
really shows you
beyond christmas and this will have
effects well beyond christmas is the
enormous tale of these lockdowns the lie
that we were told a year ago beginning
with the 15 days to slow the spread that
are now in the 590th day to slow the
spread
was that you could shut down
the country
really shut down the entire world and
then that would just be fine and there
would be no consequences you just lock
people up for
weeks and weeks and months and months
and now well over a year
you stop making stuff you stop shipping
stuff
you stop being productive
and then that would be fine and you can
just turn it on again
you can turn off the world and turn it
on again
i don't particularly like ayn rand's
book atlas shrugged i think it's a
pretty stupid book and her philosophy is
awful however you got to give the woman
credit here the book is about turning
off the motor of the world and stopping
stopping the productive uh aspects of of
the world economy
and uh and and recognizing that there
are terrible consequences of that
we are seeing that right now okay so at
least in that narrow aspect that is
correct and what does the white house
have to tell us about this so yeah you
know hey look nothing to see here just
yeah you're not gonna get your christmas
presents if anyone has tried to order
anything over the past six months you'll
know it's very difficult i moved into a
house for the first time you know i was
living in a small apartment and i moved
into a house in tennessee so i needed a
bunch of furniture i still don't have a
lot of that furniture because
the supply chains are completely
destroyed and that is going to continue
for a long time so if you want to get
your little kitties a christmas present
i would start stocking up now and
speaking of these
coveted lockdowns
i guess the worse it is for the economy
the worse it is for our political system
in some ways
the better it is for the culture things
are getting worse and worse and worse
but people are recognizing that even
people who are not traditionally rock
ribbed conservatives people who are not
necessarily traditionally on our side
they're beginning to wake up and say wow
this
liberal ruling class
there's something really really
wrong here
i i'm i'm trying to think of the the
people well you noticed this a little
bit with the metoo movement you'd see a
couple of
left wingers waking up and saying wow
the
the right wing here is actually making a
little bit more sense well you notice
that jk rowling right jk rowling the
author of harry potter is a left-wing
feminist but she's now agreeing with the
right on the transgender issue because
the issue has gotten so crazy and here
here in our own country i think the
clearest example of this is joe rogan
joe rogan who is now being vilified by
the media is no
rock-ribbed conservative
joe rogan was a bernie bro he supported
the furthest left candidate in the
presidential race last cycle last year
and yet
because joe has sort of seen through the
haze and the fog and the lies seen
behind the curtain of this lying media
joe rogan is now on the side of
conservatives and he called out cnn to
their face
joe rogan invited sanjay gupta cnn's
chief medical correspondent onto his
show and he had a simple question
does it bother you that your network
totally lied about me you're talking
about a drug that's been given out to
billions and billions of people a drug
that was responsible for one of the
inventors of it making nobel prize nobel
prize in 2015 15. yeah yeah a drug that
has been shown to stop viral replication
in vitro you know that right why would
they lie and say that's horsty warmer i
can afford people medicine [ __ ]
this is ridiculous it's just a lot like
anyone but don't you think that a lie
like that is dangerous on a news network
when you know that they know they're
lying you know that they know that i
took medicine like here it is
this is ivermectin you gotta sit right
here somebody gave it to me
all right hang on i i do the thing is
that we're we're like going so fast like
i feel like i'm missing i'm missing you
i want that's a problem that your news
network is not lies
well i don't i don't dude what did they
say they lied what did they say i was
taking horse dewormer first of all it
was prescribed to me by a doctor yeah
yeah a long time they shouldn't have
said it was a bunch of other medications
if you got a human
pill because there were people that were
taking it the veterinary medication and
i you're not obviously you got it from a
doctor so that it shouldn't be called
that ivormectin can be a very effective
medication
there it is there thank you sanjay thank
you cnn for admitting this when you got
totally called out on it and backed into
a corner and you tried every which way
to evade it i can't believe sanjay
gupta's first reaction here which is
well uh oh hold on i mean we're
we're going kind of fast aren't we what
do you mean joe rogan speaks very slowly
and he's saying one thing he's it's not
like he's moving a mile a minute here
and jumping from topic to topic he goes
hey does it bother you that you guys
lied about this drug that i took
joe i just gosh slow down buddy okay
i'll does it
bother you
and then so finally gupta can't get out
of it and rogan's not letting him off
the hook and gupta finally has to admit
okay yeah all right i'm sure we said
that you took horse dewormer and
yeah i'm looking at the pill bottle that
was prescribed by the diner i guess
yeah i guess you didn't okay can we move
on now can we move on now please and joe
rogan won't let him move on can i just
come back to the one i want to talk
about no two things on the ledger you
have before we get to that does it
bother you that the news network you
worked for
out and out lied well outright lied
about me taking horse dewormer they they
shouldn't have said that why did they do
that i don't know you didn't ask i
didn't think that you're the magical guy
over there i didn't ask i should have
asked because they did it without such
glee no
i watched
no no joe and they did do it with glee
and they did it without any even hint of
shame and then so when he goes yeah well
okay maybe they shouldn't have done that
can we please move on now no we can't
move on why just why did they do that
can you give me an answer well i don't
know
what do you mean you don't know you're
their top medical correspondent sanjay
gupta and you thought that you could
just get away with this and you could
giggle and say oh
all those stupid idiot rube nazi
alt-right whatever whatever label they
want to say
supporting bitter clinging rubes or are
just gobbling up horse dewormer what a
bunch of idiots
oh and joe rogan's one of them yeah he's
one of them now too even though he was a
bernie bro like five minutes ago yeah
now we hate him we like we used to like
him when he was on the left but now
he has
said like sort of some slightly critical
things about biden yeah he's a dumb
idiot who eats horse gum and paste right
so all i would say to joe rogan here is
yes slay queen slay yes
awesome and what i would say to everyone
who listened to that is
look at how they fold when they're
called on it
look at how they fold
you know i guess this is the phenomenon
of the so and so destroys debates you
know
what's the format it's conservative
person destroys liberal person in a
debate and then you post a five-minute
clip and you see left wingers getting
their most sacred cherished
maxims and moral edicts
knocked down before their very eyes with
facts and logic and so i guess we at the
daily wire sort of pioneered this
particular
genre but the reason that it went viral
is because
one
the right-wing arguments the
conservative arguments tend to be
more persuasive than the left-wing
slogans and because the wingers are
unprepared
99 times out of 100 the left wingers
can't respond to the conservative
arguments i think this is because the
conservative arguments are stronger but
even if you don't think that
the most basic reason why the
left-wingers can't respond to the
right-wingers is because the
left-wingers are never exposed to those
arguments the left-wingers are living in
a bubble ju they are they are dominating
the media and the big tech companies and
the educational institutions and the
government and so they're just unaware
of their own bs and they're never called
out on it it's like a fish in water
they're just not aware of these crazy
ridiculous premises that they're moving
around in and so anytime
that some conservative is finally able
to break through the bubble whether it's
because they get to speak on a college
campus
through sheer tyranny of will or because
they make it onto some tv show or
because they get sanjay gupta to sit
down they fold they fold because there
is no defense for the preposterous
notion that
any people who
look into ivermectin are eating horse
dewormer okay it's just not it's just
not true so the question is
what else are they lying about
and this is where we get to my friend
steven crowder i'm going to try to speak
to my friend steven crowder a little
little bit later today
you probably haven't heard much from him
on youtube recently because he's been
kicked off of youtube
and the way youtube works is you get
strikes
so you get strikes usually for just
saying true things if those true things
are inconvenient but they'll give you
strikes for any number of reasons they
find your content offensive they say
your content is misleading even if it's
leading i don't know it's the opposite
of misleading even if it's honest
content then especially they'll go after
you and so crowder now has two strikes
on his channel that means he's going to
be down for a week third strike you're
out
third strike
steven crowder one of the most popular
channels on youtube is gone forever why
is steven crowder gone well it's
actually a little bit our fault
our fault here at the daily wire
we broke a story the other day this was
a major news story about how in loudoun
county a girl was raped and she was
raped
in a bathroom allegedly and she was
raped allegedly by
a guy who sometimes wears a dress who
probably doesn't belong in that girl's
bathroom but the left now believes that
men should enter the women's bathrooms
and they tell us there's no risk of any
women being harmed here and then a woman
was harmed and the school covers it up
so we broke that story
media the establishment media didn't
want to cover it finally now actually
the washington post has had to pick it
up which we'll get to in a second but
stephen crowder covers the story
that was enough
here is what the youtube lawyer wrote to
stephen crowder
on october 30th mr crowder uploaded
another video that youtube has
determined continues his prior conduct
the video contains a segment that
targets the transgender community in an
offensive manner for example by
indicating that trans people pose a rape
threat to women
all right i'll finish reading it before
we answer this consistent with the
recklessness provisions of its hate
speech policy youtube has removed this
video from the service and assessed a
strike against the stephen crowder
channel per youtube strikes policy this
results in a one-week upload freeze for
the channel further violation of
youtube's hate speech policy will result
in additional penalties this is an
acceleration of the policy that i
violated a couple of weeks ago
where
our social media team caught it in time
but do you remember this there was a
portion of my show that was censored on
youtube
uh it was last week or two weeks ago
and
the the terrible thing that i did the
awful misconduct i engaged in was that i
quoted the director of the cdc
dr rochelle walensky i don't know am i
even allowed to say it now well i'll say
it and if they censor me i guess steven
crowder and i'll go down together but
what the cdc director said was that
what stephen crowder did
was
he
just read
our news story he just read a news story
that now even the washington post has to
carry but because the reality
contradicted the left's narrative namely
that letting men into the women's
bathroom can never result in any bad
thing happening to women letting men
into the women's changing room can never
result in any bad thing happening to
women because reality contradicted the
lies of the left stephen crowder doesn't
get to have a youtube channel at least
for a week possibly not
forever that is that's an actual
sacrifice crowder is sacrificing money
right now a lot of money he's
sacrificing his voice he's sacrificing
his career for stating a plain truth
and it's it is going to get worse they
as the reality continues to contradict
their narrative they are going to turn
up the censorship we're seeing it happen
in real time
you know we had a lot of exciting
announcements come out this has been a
crazy week all right we started out the
week we were at the ryman auditorium for
backstage live i have been on the
verdict live tour then in madison
wisconsin right now i'm coming to you
from houston texas finally heading back
to tennessee pretty soon
this past week at the ryman we announced
that the daily wire is fulfilling their
promise of bringing you even more
non-woke content that you truly will not
find anywhere else we've got the adam
corolla show uh which is uh or rather
we've got adam kroll who's the host of
the atom coral the show he's a great guy
he goes all over you see him at prageru
you've seen him on a lot of our stuff
well we're about to launch a new comedy
series with him
that is coming to the daily wire in 2022
there is no better time to join than now
head on over to dailywire.com
subscribe enter code 2022 for 25 off
your membership steelywire.com subscribe
code
202022 just in case you don't know what
2022 is for 25 off a new daily wire
membership stay tuned for more updates
and content also also want to mention
just a little tease here uh barry weiss
this weekend's sunday special is going
to add to this kind of craziness that
we've been ginning up here at the daily
wire
bench is going to be joined by barry
weiss terrific writer journalist and the
voice of her own excellent podcast
honestly
they sit down they make sense of what's
going on so go check that out on the
sunday special we'll be right back with
a lot more
steven crowder
i hate to say nice things about the guy
but he's actually sacrificing something
right now he's telling the truth and
he's being punished financially
professionally
maybe personally soon enough and he's
not the only one
kyrie irving
this is someone that i wasn't paying
particular attention to
more than a month ago i do not follow
sports all that closely the only sport i
really follow is baseball kyrie irving
is a basketball player
but kyrie irving has caught my attention
and he's caught my attention because he
is taking
a stand and he is being punished for it
kyrie irving
one of the most prominent athletes in
the world
is being benched because he refuses to
take the fouchy ouchie you think i
really want to give up on my dream to go
after a championship
you think i really just want to give up
my job
you think i really just want to sit at
home and and and not go after the things
with my teammates that i i've been able
to grow with to learn with to learn that
it takes sacrifice in this space because
we could be easily at home chilling with
our families but we're choosing to go
out there and perform
you know and even in that job
like that that's a dream come true i've
been working on that since i was in
fourth grade you think i want to give up
my livelihood because of a mandate
because i don't have accommodations
because i'm not vaccinated come on
i'm not gonna be used
as an as as a person in this agenda you
know like i'm not i'm not even gonna
speak on that i'm just saying like it
should be
not it should not be divided amongst all
of us it should just be understood and
respected a principled stand
as i've mentioned before
there are plenty of reasons
why one would not get the vaccine
kyrie irving might be looking at the
fact that he is a young ostensibly very
healthy person and the rate of him or
the chances rather of him going to the
hospital or dying from the coronavirus
are exceptionally low he might be
looking at
the way that the vaccines were produced
i don't know i'm just i'm not saying
this applies directly to irving i'm
saying these are reasons that people
might object to taking the vaccine
because they were
developed and in some cases produced
with
cells derived stem cells derived from
aborted fetal lines
now that would be one reason why he
might be looking at a study from uc
davis which showed that for some young
men the risk from the vaccine is
actually greater than the risk from the
virus itself study came out not that
long ago
you might be looking at the many widely
acknowledged side effects from the
vaccine the side effects that we're told
occur in rare cases but don't forget
the risk to young healthy people from
the coronavirus is also quite low
risks from the vaccine like myocarditis
pericarditis nerve damage
blood clots we've seen these these are
real they have been acknowledged by the
cdc and the fda
maybe kyrie's making a prudential
judgment here and he's going to pay the
price for that
he is going to be benched in the prime
of his career making a lot a lot of
money he's going to stop making all of
that money
he's going to stop getting to do the
thing that he's
best known for that he's flourishing in
that he really loves to do
he's making a real
sacrifice that's that's pretty admirable
and when people make these kinds of
sacrifices
the truth has a funny way of getting out
right the truth has a funny way of
getting out
so
crowder right now because he was reading
our story on loudoun county now his
channel's down
but you know what
the establishment media have to pick up
the story this was this was a pretty
shocking thing i saw it yesterday
loudon
county student accused in sexual
assaults at two county schools sparking
outrage from parents that's in the
washington post this i think is the
first time
that
reporting has gone in this direction
usually what happens is
the left-wing media investigate and
report on stories and then the
right-wing media read those stories try
to take out the bs and and try to tell
you what actually happened based on the
investigative work of the left-wing
outlets because investigative journalism
is very expensive and it requires a big
ecosystem and conservatives until very
recently haven't really had it
so that's usually the direction it goes
in
in this case dailywire broke the story
and the washington post had to pick it
up and they won't give us credit for it
and they won't even acknowledge us but
what this means is that at least in some
cases
it is now conservatives who are setting
the news cycle
it's conservatives who are setting the
agenda
this is just one story how many other
stories are there like this
and you're seeing these protests right
now at the loudoun county school board
just the other day more than 60
concerned parents students and residents
spoke up at the school board meeting
many demanding the resignation of the
superintendent
scott ziegler in the wake of allegations
that he and the school district covered
up sexual assaults
now ziegler said over the summer in a
meeting that this school district did
not have quote any record of assaults
occurring in our restrooms and it turns
out that that was not true this guy
should go down he should lose his job he
might be a nice guy very if he was lying
he obviously wasn't a particularly nice
guy doesn't matter the fact that these
parents are showing up and demanding
that these people get fired that is a
good thing that is the first step back
into reasserting some kind of political
power this is the way to do it okay in
our
desiccated culture we are told that
compassion is when you go really soft
and you're just really nice and you
don't rock the boat and you just go
along to get along and that's compassion
right now sometimes compassion means you
got to be tough sometimes compassion
means you got to pick a side there's a
story that very few people are reporting
on that i think actually
tells you a lot about this culture right
now it's a story over in the united
kingdom and it has to do with churches
michael nasir ali i might be
mispronouncing that he's the former
bishop of rochester he's one of the best
known anglican clerics in the world
is uh reportedly about to be ordained a
catholic priest he's converting from the
church of england
to catholicism and he's because of that
he was a bishop but he he can't be a
bishop in the catholic church he's he's
married he you know it wouldn't work out
all that well so he's he's taking
i think a promotion obviously in the
church that he's now going to be a
member of but he's taking a demotion in
terms of his role in that church
the reason i bring this up is not even
to make a religious point it's it's to
show that this is a deeper
representation of a phenomenon that we
are seeing in politics
namely distinctions are becoming clearer
okay people are not really standing in
the middle of the road anymore if you
stand in the middle of the road you're
gonna get hit by a truck the church of
england especially in in recent decades
has really fallen and they've embraced
all the wokest most radical
left-wing trappings of of the world and
they seem to have really really really
lost their way
and people have tried they've always
viewed the church of england as a kind
of middle ground between the low church
of evangelicalism and the high church of
catholicism they want to have a sort of
middle way but there is no real middle
way here okay the
you gotta you gotta pick a side okay so
regardless of your views of these
religious questions we're seeing this
play out at every aspect of the politics
and of the culture and clarity can be a
very good thing it can lead to a little
little tough road a little bit of a
bumpy road in in the meantime and we're
seeing that throughout our economy our
political system and our in our
spiritual life frankly
but that clarity can be a very good
thing clarity is
obviously it helps you see it helps you
sanitize your culture hopefully it gives
us a path forward
we got to get to the mailbag my absolute
favorite time of the week
all right
first question up from james
michael i've heard your stance on dating
in high school as a high schooler who
listens to you i would like to ask what
is the point of a high school
relationship you're most likely not
going to get married so what is the
point
well
i think you ought to write this question
to my wife who also happens to have been
my high school sweetheart james
you're telling maybe you should write
this question into my grandparents who
also happen to have been high school
sweethearts james i think people can you
know i've joked about this on the show
before but i said my wife and i dated in
high school then we split up for college
which i think is now a statutory
requirement in our modern culture and
then we realized that was crazy and we
shouldn't have broken up after high
school and uh you know we got back
together then we got married now we have
our cute little child and so i think
actually
dating in high school can be a very good
thing it obviously can lead to marriage
it can it can lead to bad marriages but
some of the best marriages i've ever
seen have been between high school
sweethearts and the reason for this is
the way that we look at marriage today
is that marriage is something you do
once you've really completely grown up
and you've done everything you want to
do and you've traveled all the places
you want to go and you've slept with all
the people you want to sleep with and
you've had all the fun wild crazy
experiences that you wanted to have and
now you just need
someone to settle down your life and
you're going to have a partnership
and you're going to you know produce a
child together and you're going to agree
on these certain things and check a
bunch of boxes
i don't think that's really how it works
i asked my grandfather on it was the
occasion of his 60th wedding anniversary
i said
how do you uh have a good marriage you
know you guys have the greatest marriage
i've ever seen how how did you do it he
said well
patience is very important
shared experience is very important
going all the way back you know to those
early early days
and in his case because he was a navy
captain frequent absence he said that
doesn't hurt either but certainly we can
agree on the first two and that shared
experience thing is very important
because in some cases people will grow
apart
if they have a bad marriage they're
probably going to grow apart but also
you can grow together
my wife and i do not think the same
things that we thought or view the world
in the same way that we did when we were
in high school
and we it's not that we even viewed the
world exactly in the same way as each
other when we were in high school but we
have grown
together we so we we now have this kind
of different view and that that view
every single minute more and more
resembles the way that she and i see the
world together
so i think that is important i'm not adv
i think the what you're getting at in
your question here is you're saying why
why should why are people screwing
around in high school that's not a good
idea they shouldn't do that yeah you
people should you know probably
not make the mistakes of youth and
probably many of them are going to make
the mistakes of youth and you know they
shouldn't get carried away and do do
sorts of bad things but i think dating
in high school can be a very very
wonderful thing i'm living evidence of
that
next question up from adam dear mr
knowles
as you are italian i have a few
questions for you
what is your favorite pasta favorite
italian dish and what is and isn't
acceptable on pizza and what is
pineapple why is pineapple not allowed
on pizza thank you for everything you do
i really enjoyed speechless my favorite
pasta dish would be my wife's speaking
of my wife would be my wife's lasagna
which is a fresh homemade lasagna with
the homemade
pasta itself you know you do it in the
little grinder thing and it has a nice
pork kind of ragu and then it's but it's
got a nice bechamel and it's just it's
absolutely delicious what is my favorite
italian dish more broadly i don't know
veal saltimbocca maybe
uh what is
oh and why is pineapple not allowed on
pizza because it's gross and weird and
you know i don't i don't think
christopher columbus never had it marco
polo never had it okay it's it's weird
it's not good the the impulse to put
pineapple on pizza is that you want a
little sweet and a little savory right
that's that's why it goes with ham on
pizza but that is very
day classy my friends no if you want
the sweet and the savory on the pizza
you need to order the greatest pizza
toppings which is sausage and onion the
sausage is better than the ham the onion
much better than the pineapple both a
little
subtler in the way they play with those
flavors and very very delicious thank
you for enjoying speechless from mike
hello fellow michael i wanted to ask you
why you think most people in hollywood
are libs are they selling their soul to
the devil living in fun now but damn to
eternal damnation why is it so
disproportionately liberal sincerely a
fellow covet 19 survivor
yes
yes in part
to your suggestions
people who work in the arts
tend to be a little unsettled tend to be
a little bit kooky and eccentric
and so that i guess would allow them to
uh
or impel them to be a little more
liberal
but there's a really practical reason as
to why hollywood itself is so liberal
it actually has to do with the supreme
court
in the old days there was something
called the studio system during the
studio system
actors and actresses and people working
on movies had real jobs and so they
would sign a contract and they'd sign a
contract with a studio and they would
just make movies with the studio and
they'd get a regular sort of salary and
regular compensation and they they could
look forward to the kind of work that
they were going to do and they actually
worked for a company the supreme court
struck that down and this in the middle
of the 20th century the supreme court
strikes down the studio system says it's
got all these various problems and so
then everyone became a freelancer and
freelancers are nuts i mean i remember
this i have worked in
hollywood to varying degrees over the
years and
if you've ever met an actor or someone
working in the arts you know their their
schedules are all over the place
uh in in some ways i guess it's a return
to the
more natural state of artists i'm
thinking of pinocchio you know high
diddle ddd the actor afterlife for me hi
diddle dee do you sleep till after two
you know you're you're staying up really
late you're you're sleeping in you're
gonna work on tuesday but not work on
thursday and that kind of tumultuous
life leads people into a more liberal
lifestyle because it's just not as
settled certainly not as disciplined and
it can allow your passions to run away
with you
from sarah
michael i want to get your opinion on a
few things all right well i've got my
opinion to give sarah one as a religious
person what level of language violence
sex is acceptable to consume in a movie
i'll take these one by one
i think that
any degree
just about can be acceptable
depending on the context
so for instance the bible includes lots
of pretty gory raunchy stuff mass
slaughter
incest
lots of
lots of yucky things lots of very bad
things
um you know uh
ritualistic killing the passion for
goodness sakes you know so
in the context of the bible it's
obviously not pornography it's serving a
very important purpose the most
important narrative purpose that there
could be
namely leading toward your salvation
so there i think it's fine but there are
movies and tv shows that include much
lower levels of raunchiness and sex and
gore and violence and things like that
that i think are not acceptable because
they do not serve a purpose and they're
just merely titillating or just merely
shocking and they're basically just
pornography there is actually a
difference here between obscenity and
real art and as justice potter stewart
famously put it although he is derided
for it you actually can know it when you
see it second question you ask what
level of those elements would be
acceptable to take part in if you were
acting in it this is a tricky question i
used to think that anything was
acceptable you know you're an actor
that's your job so you're going to kiss
someone sleep with someone it's no big
deal that's just your job and don't
worry about it but it is i've actually
rethought this view because the way that
acting is taught these days and the way
that actors are trained for the past 100
years or so is in systems that were
derived from freud
and then kind of systematized by the
stanislavski
system the stanislavski school at the
moscow art theater and then
developed by lee strasberg into the
method or by stella adler into her
technique or sanford meisner or the
various people associated with the group
theater but it all comes from the
unconscious so the idea is if you want
to put on a good performance
and pretend that you are you know
pretend right play act that you're in
love with this person on screen that the
best way to do that is to actually sort
of fall in love with the person because
then you're not just making these
conscious representational kinds of
choices as an actor on screen but you're
actually behaving organically right this
is the this is the buzzword in modern
acting but if you are doing that if
you're really acting organically then
you really have fallen in love with
someone and in that way it is sort of a
betrayal and so
my friend drew clavin very often would
remind me especially back in my actor
days that actors historically are
associated with criminals and
prostitutes
it's a little bit of a writer dig at the
actors
but but there is something to that i
mean you you are playing a dangerous
game so that i don't i don't know if i
were if i hadn't hung up my spurs i
don't know if i would still feel
comfortable doing that and three who
would be the worst daily wire
personality if they booked a role in one
of these new movies well i'll give you
the real answer and he would agree with
this 100 is ben
ben can't act ben can barely keep a
straight face if we're doing a 10 second
video shoot and uh i suspect his answer
to this would be yeah because i don't i
don't want to play pretend okay facts
don't care about my feelings okay i just
want to give you the straight facts and
i'm not going to do that and it is it is
really one of his strengths um but as a
result yeah he's not the best actor
from
lindsay
michael i had a rough go in the dating
world as of late i would love to hear
your advice on dealing with being led on
i was recently talking to a guy and
thought things were going well he said a
lot of things to me that suggested he
was interested in something long term
but then ghosted me we had plans to see
each other again but haven't heard back
from my last text about plan details
i don't want to double text again but
can't understand what happened to and
know that it'll bother me for a while my
friend says i should let it go and then
if i move on guys like this always come
back after you no longer want them
would love to hear your advice on what
to do when this happens or any insight
you might have as to why it does
sincerely apparently the ghosts have
come out early this year great great
sign off
well you've contradicted yourself here
you've said
look maybe i'll move on and the best
part about moving on is he might come
back to me well then you haven't moved
on if you're waiting for him to come
back to you then you obviously haven't
moved on so it hasn't worked yes do men
get more attracted when you
don't you know throw yourself at them
yes of course that that certainly
happens so if you're doing this as a
tactic to try to entice this guy to like
you more then tactically i suppose that
would probably work but i would just be
direct i'm i'm a big fan of directness
in these sorts of things if the guy is
not interested he should tell you that
he should not lead you on and certainly
you shouldn't ghost people that's that's
not nice um so i would just say like hey
buddy look i had a nice time uh but if
you're not into it that's cool it's no
big deal but just uh just let me know
and you know that's that's no no hard
feelings um
i would not allow a man to remain in
this squishy kind of middle ground
because one suspects what he's doing is
just kind of playing his field checking
out his other options but he wants to
keep you in the back pocket in case it
doesn't work out and i would not let him
do that i mean that's not much of a man
a man should be decisive and should
should follow through on on his
decisions wish you the best of luck
lindsay the guy sounds like a jerk so i
frankly if i were you i'd probably ghost
him but if you want closure i would i
would send him the text from arun hello
arun dear dr koffe
you've regularly discussed your thesis
that the left wishes for the appearance
of the thing rather than the actual
thing this is true this is why libs
drink you know
decaf coffee or whatever this is why the
libs
call
relationships that are not marriage
marriage because they want the
appearance of of the marriage but they
don't want to actually do the things
that or they're not willing to do the
things that are actually involved in
marriage
this is exactly how i feel about your
impression of dr fauci i could listen to
your approximation of his voice for
hours
but to hear him speak for even a moment
about his love of tyranny's infuriating
and insufferable does that make me a
leftist no it means you have common
sense my friend
because when i do the impression of dr
fauci you know
the dr fauci impression is not going to
harm you it's not the dr fauci may harm
you and take away your liberties and
your way of life but the dr fauci
impression probably uh will not
final little bit here from brandon
michael i'd like to take a snapshot of
the let's go branded movement right now
and save it as the slogan for my
political campaign in 2032 against my
future party rival knowles 2032 the
authoritarian moment yes
these are both very important slogans
it's tough because i you know obviously
agree with both of them and strongly
support both of them there's more to
brandon's question
we're gonna have to save that for next
week i'm gonna try to get this back in
the mailbag next week okay because i
don't want to leave leave brandon here
look we're all very supportive of
brandon let's go brandon i'll see you
all on monday
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
bori our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright dailywire2021
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin